hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll longtime listeners will probably
have figured out that one of the things
I try to do here on mindscape is to
bring the world's experts to talk about
the topic that we're going to talk about
in that episode so in other words less
of an emphasis on pundits or general
purpose writers or dilatant or other
podcasters things like that not that
there's anything wrong with that I'm a
podcaster kind of a dilatant myself but
when I get into a topic I wanted to get
into it with the people who have really
spent a lot of time becoming
professionals researching this kind of
thing today's podcast is an exception to
that but it is the best possible
exception I have zero qualms about this
one very very happy that it worked out
Kelly and Zach weinersmith are a wife
and husband team and Zach of course will
be well known to many of you he is a web
comic artist and writer he's the artist
for Saturday Morning Breakfast Cereal
SMBC the very well-known web comic right
up there with XKCD in terms of nerd
credibility on the web so I'm happy to
have had both of those two artists now
on the show and Kelly is actually a PhD
ecologist in adjunct faculty at Rice
University but we are not going to be
talking for the most part about either
ecology or cartooning I should also
mention to be fair that Zack and Kelly
have written a previous book that was a
science book
and Zack is the author of other things
like a kids book version of Bale wolf
called Bay Wolf that I can recommend
very very highly but the topic today is
space settlement the idea of taking
human beings flying them to a space
station or the moon or Mars or wherever
and living there as a sustainable
Society for Generations at a time is
this possible how would it happen what
are the obstacles and so forth and what
I love about Kelly and Zach is they just
dive into it they're super smart people
who take their job seriously they want
to explain things in a way that
everybody can understand but they don't
come in with an agenda so they're
rightfully proud of the ginormous number
of footnotes in the book that they have
just came out called a city on Mars can
we settle space should we settle space
and have we really thought this through
they've done a lot of research and
because they're not in the field they
can give a somewhat balanced view of an
area that often doesn't have enough
balance because the people who devote
their lives to the exploration and
settlement of space are unsurprisingly
kind of on one side they think it's a
great thing right and so Kelly and Zach
also think it would be a great thing but
they're very very cleare eyed about what
the challenges are and the challenges
are quite large so this is a fun podcast
it's super educational but I also think
it's super Fair it gives a perspective
on this that we really should keep in
mind because I think a lot of us
including myself would like to see
humankind extend itself to other
environments but if we're going to do
that successfully we got to know what
the challenges really are this is the
podcast to come to if you want to know
what those challenges are so let's
[Music]
go
KY and Zack weeners Smith welcome to the
mindscape podcast thanks for having us
so I'm going to ask you a question this
is probably like a little out of left
field not the question you usually get
or have ever gotten before but have
people had sex in space is that possible
to do this is be any fun we have we have
different views we do go uh yes we do we
do well so let us be clear that this is
a probabilistic question there is no
certainty so the question is what value
do you assign to the likelihood that it
has happened I I hit somewhere like one
to five percent chance that it's
happened and I feel like you know if
you've ever met a human you yeah you
know that humans are gonna find a way to
have sex in space and so there's no
people will tell you that like oh yeah
we know for sure it happened and every
time we searched for a story where it
was like oh for sure happened
we were not able to confirm that it for
sure but there has been a married couple
in space and Zack points out that they
were in the shuttle and it's tiny and
probably you wouldn't want to have sex
with your you know colleagues and you're
all very professional and your careers
are on the line and I still don't think
that would stop me
but you and so maybe that would it takes
two people to that's right you would you
would be deterred but um listen listen
go
my wife has a dirty mind
and listen here's the thing so you she's
using what I think it was the
stochiometric approach which is you take
like tendency towards sex and you
multiply it by hours in space and you
arrive at probility which is an
incorrect approach because you have to
look at the the actual facts so consider
that like up until the early 80s it was
all dudes in space and I understand that
that doesn't Ian it depends on what
definition of sex we want to use
but these homophobic societies not to
make this too serious so the odds that
like careerist astronauts are going to
risk it all for a little you know boy on
boy action in the uh the um space shower
seems Seems dicey um I would say also if
you know so I I think one area where
Kelly and I probably agree is the mo if
it happened it was almost certainly in
one of the late Russian space stations
would you agree with that and and the
reason I think we would agree with that
is one they were less monitored so now
there's like Perpetual monitoring just
because you can constantly send signal
whereas there would have been Gap back
then so one there was a little there you
know it only takes about a minute and a
half to have a good time and
uh great time yeah great time is a
minute 45 there you go but um no so so
if it happened you know and so like the
ISS it would be very hard to get away
with you'd basically have to have a
conspiracy between International where
would you do it she's shaking her head
at me I don't know it could be in the
rest for like
no they no wait they've got their little
Cubbies that they sleep in John I told
you we don't give short answers they fit
one person understand you're gonna get
you're gonna get like carbon Narcosis as
you exhale into the coffin sized cubby
hole so anyway so if we agree that it
almost certainly had to happen on a
Russian space station almost no women
went to those stations that's not true
shuttle mirr there were plenty of uh
shuttle people there short and we
disagree there's no way Shannon Shannon
Lucid was the only long-term woman there
you have to be long term you only have
to be on there for a minute and a half
okay but Shannon loose who was like a
librarian from Oklahoma in between being
an astronaut I just don't she was
excited about pillow I have another
human nature data point that is relevant
but is actually against Kelly's argument
because not sure I want to hear it if I
were part of the first set of people to
ever have sex in space once I'd been
retired from being an astronaut you
think I wouldn't let people know about
this like this is a historic thing
that's right that's right someone's
going to be first that that is both a
good point and a good insight into human
behavior let me I hate to side with my
own wife on this but I I would say so
for example Lyn Sher uh is a biographer
uh of of of Sally Ry very um good friend
of many of the women astronauts in the
program going back to the 70s and she
said um she knew the first woman who
menstruated in space who has to my
knowledge still not been identified
uh so like that's a little bit less of a
thing to be known for it is it is less
thrilling but but but but it is like you
know astronauts keep secrets about
certain things so I I I think there
might be like you can't use the standard
anti-conspiracy Theory argument that
Heins blab because this is a very
special set of humans who are extremely
career oriented um fair enough fair
enough okay well I wanted to get that
you know probably the only time you'll
get to talk about this because it's not
very to most people but I think that
most of what concerned about in your new
book which we will note is called a city
on Mars can we settle space should we
settle space and have we really thought
this through slightly Mr Peanut Butter
esque uh title there and it is mostly
about gravity right like you're mostly
thinking about literally being on a
planet you're talking about settling
things in space we're not going to for
the rest of the hour talk mostly about
zero g flights is that right that's
right yeah the three places that we
focus on the most are the Moon Mars and
rotating space stations and out of all
of those we think that Mars is probably
the most likely yeah well the Moon is
the closest I mean at least until we
build a a big space station so uh how
would it work like what is what is the
scenario that we are contemplating here
we're talking about not just flying
human beings to Mars but literally
building a settlement and staying there
right what what is what is the situation
we're both imagining and then critiquing
yeah sure sure sure so the you know you
can get a little lost in the
nomenclature there have been attempts to
like disambiguate like what's an outpost
and what's a settlement and stuff but so
generally speaking we would say
settlement is somewhere where people can
have kids um uh and so you're probably
at least talking like a few thousand
people the scenario I would add that
like a lot of space expansionist
Advocate types are concerned with is in
particular a settlement that has the you
know set of qualities that would allow
for permanence in the sense of like
Earth could explode or just lose contact
and you could carry on self sustained
yeah self- sustaining yeah yeah yeah
permanently self-sustaining which is
like you know the thing about permanent
self-sustaining is it's like you have to
think in terms of generations right like
so so that that's a whole can of worms
but like it's a huge huge thing to be
permanently self-sustaining um so uh I'd
like to think you know you know we're
critiquing it at several levels uh but
we're um uh I I I think a better way to
think about it than in terms of like
population and stuff is to think about
the components that you need to succeed
at to to pull this off and um so most
basically you have to have a kind of
survival bubble uh that can provide all
the consumables you need either locally
or by shipping them in at Great expense
um outside of that the next big thing is
usually shielding because most places in
space are going to be assaulted by
radiation uh you know Earth has this
nice thing called a magnetosphere Mars
has very weak magnetism uh the moon I
believe has none at all um and so you're
going to have to provide against that
and then that you get to like more
biosocial science stuff you need to have
like a local ecosystem uh I mean unless
you're willing to truck in enormous
amounts of consumables right you have to
be able to grow plants because Plants
provide both oxygen and food uh and you
have to have like medical services and
to be able to provide uh reproduction
which is you know a huge thing for us is
that this is like basically undeveloped
science human reproduction offw World um
there's there's more I could get into
but but yeah the these we will we will
but I guess what I wanted to get at was
let's say that instead of writing a book
and telling the truth you were working
for NASA or for some equivalent agency
or private Corporation and wanted to set
out the road map for how it would work
like what are the steps that are
involved in creating human settle
settlement let's say on Mars although
we'll talk about the other
options well so I'd say first you want
to sorry I'd say first you want to
understand
how the human body responds to space
before you send people out there without
a plan to bring them back so one problem
that we have is that most of our data
have come from places like the
International Space Station where you
have a station orbiting Earth in freef
Fall so we know that no gravity is bad
for our bones and our muscles and that
fluid shifts and impacts vision and we
know that that's bad especially over the
long term um but we actually don't know
how bad it gets over the long term
because the longest stay is like a year
and a half
uh and the moon and Mars the moon has
one sixth Earth's gravity and the mar
and Mars has about 40% maybe that's
enough to get rid of all of the bone
problems and the muscle problems but we
just we don't know right now we don't
have a lot okay you I'm sorry but you
are not doing a good job at being NASA
and giving me the road map
you're you're instantly jumping to the
problems oh oh okay um all right so
human health uh but no literally how we
get there what is the plan like do we do
we build one rocket and go first do we
first go to to orbit and build a space
station to like how many Rockets do we
need like what is the what is the set of
steps that must be taken to make yeah
yeah so let me so there are a lot of
different proposals it might be
interesting to think about the one fun
Brown was proposing way back in the 50s
um that we deviated from in favor of the
Apollo program and his proposal which
which you hate to like s with an ex-nazi
but like um but but his proposal which
which you know setting aside cost is way
more sensible than what we ended up
doing which was you build a very large
space station which would consist of
like 80 people and the reason you do
that is because now you have a
manufacturing facility close to Earth
that can work in zerog and that means
that when it's time to go to the Moon
you can go in style so you can for him
that means like sending geologist and
all this stuff but it also means if you
wanted to set up a substantial base on
the moon which you absolutely want to do
before Mars then you it would really
help to have a manufacturing system
there there are debates about this I
mean you know you know in some World
Rockets get so cheap you just send the
Rockets straight to the moon but but
let's just say it um and then what you
would want to do is really build out on
the moon and the reason you want to
build out on the moon we argue is that
you just need you know it's almost less
about science than like something like
an employee handbook there's just a lot
of stuff you don't know until you get
there right uh and and and so you know
we need kind of best practices for
converting this like dead horrible soil
I mean it's not the same as Mars but
it's at least in the realm of it uh you
know converting that to an ecosystem and
like we really need to learn like like a
big track of this is learning how to
build an on-site ecosystem that can
supply most of your consumables on an
ongoing basis also that's an opportunity
while we have our base on the moon to
work out the problems and reproduction
uh which is a long way off you'd ideally
want to like scale through this is this
is what we're doing running the
settlement agency you'd want to like do
this ethically which means starting with
simple animal systems and working your
way up uh until you could be comfortable
with humans and at some point point you
know if this if this works out I I I I
know it would be very expensive there
might be an angle on tourism to fund
some of it at some point you've mastered
how to get humans to live in this
horrible place where where everything
outside of your protection bubble is is
Doom um and hopefully in the meantime
you have developed massive rocket
technology because it's going to be much
harder to get to Mars Mars is six months
inbound right the Moon is two days
inbound um and so so so there are going
to be new things to do but I think
plausibly once you've mastered how to
live like a thousand people on the moon
for some period of time like like if you
have the equivalent of our Antarctic
base at the South Pole on the moon
you're probably ready to take a stab at
Mars um I I think that would be our road
map the other big threat of that is that
the legal aspects are a little funky but
if you're just talking about research
bases even if they're quite substantial
that's all on the up and up as long as
you're not claiming to own anything
under the research
stations okay but that's very very
useful so you you are telling me that my
goal is not to build some giant rockets
and fire them at Mars but rather to go
by steps to uh I maybe explain a little
bit more about why the space station is
useful as well as going to the moon and
then if I'm going to go to the space
station anyway are do we sure we need
the moon isn't the space station even
harder we have a thousand person space
station as our trial run yeah so I think
I think at least in the old fun Brown
model he was talking about like an 80
person Space Station and I think the
basic IDE is that and this is you know I
think people have been talking about for
a long time it has yet to be proven
there's certain things that are easier
to do in Zerg plausibly building a
giganto spacecraft is there
historically um we meaning like
everybody doing space has been opposed
to rendevu I gu and I talked to an
aerospace guy and he was basically like
rendevu is really hard and if you know
the history of like the Gemini program
you know a lot of problems came from
trying to dock Gemini with a Gina which
was this like rocket system for space
and so like you part part of the weird
thing about Apollo is there is no
rendevu you just launch a skyscraper and
little pieces of it break off until
finally a teeny weeny dingy goes to the
moon right um that's no good for a
settlement uh so um you know uh uh so
you're but but is that In fairness to
the like you know people who are excited
about new developments scaling really
would help a lot um you know uh like
like getting getting a lot of Starships
rolling Starship for people who don't
know is this rocket with a the capacity
of the old Saturn 5ivs it's this giant
incredibly ridiculously huge vehicle
SpaceX is working on and more
importantly trying to make reusable so
the price of launching stuff to space
would be quite low um so for obvious
reasons I think like that kind of
scaling really makes a difference
possibly it even obviates the need for
any kind of space station because you
can just you get so good at throwing
Mass out of out of Earth um that that's
totally plausible more more more Spacey
arguments that were popular in the 70s
were maybe you you build a mass driver
on the moon eventually using all of that
capacity so you can just like use pure
electricity to slam stuff into space um
you know but that's getting a little
more speculative than we like to get but
maybe there's a little bit of a lesson
which is that gravity as annoying as it
is is actually helpful in some ways uh
in fact maybe it's just not that easy to
do manufacturing of giant things like
spacecraft in orbit because things tend
to float away and you know it's hard to
match them up because you don't have a
level and I I don't know but I could I
could imagine that it turns out to just
be easier to go to the moon and build
your Mars rocket there yeah no totally
possible and plausible and Zach and I
only researched the most important
topics and so we can tell you that
almost every single vehicle that has
been in like zerog G has had problems
with Escape of waste and uh Fe is
floating through the air on the shuttle
they were called brown trout and you uh
you don't want your brown you want your
brown trout going Downstream into the
toilets and so yeah gravity is nice for
a lot of reasons and it helps with waste
as well yeah and that's part of why one
of the one of the arguments for these
big rotating space stations which we're
fairly skeptical of but one of the
arguments is by going toward the center
you can select your gravity regime which
you know the argument is that'd be good
for manufacturing that seems like a
whole lot of work to get this benefit so
you know it hasn't been proven certainly
but uh okay so in our hypothetical road
map we're going to the Moon first we're
making sure we can live there for a
while working out some of the Kinks and
then we'll eventually go to Mars uh I
mean why not just stay on the moon is is
isn't the Moon closer and nicer what
what's so great about Mars so the moon
is closer and nicer but it lacks a lot
of stuff you're going to need for a
self-sustaining Society so the water
that it has there's small quantities of
it on the poles in these hard to get
places whereas Mars has a lot more water
just about everywhere there's still more
of it at the poles but almost anywhere
you are you can find water plus we are
carbon-based life forms and the moon has
very little carbon in fact I think most
of it is in the feal and vomit bags that
were left behind by the Apollo AST not
maybe not most a fair bit of it Con
concentrated sources um so the moon
doesn't have a lot of carbon we're gonna
need that to make humans to grow plants
and so we're gonna have to truck that in
but if you go to Mars the atmosphere is
made out of carbon dioxide and you can
break that up and there's just a lot of
things that you can do on Mars that
would be hard to do on the moon so in
terms of self- sustaining life Mars has
a lot going for it uh that the moon
doesn't as far as our road map is
concerned are we going to want to
eventually terraform Mars so that the
atmosphere is breathable or is that just
crazy talk um so I am an ecologist and I
would argue that we maybe don't
understand all of this stuff well enough
to be throwing nuclear bombs at the pole
of Mars and hoping that you get just the
right temperature and just the right
thickness of atmosphere uh so we to be
honest in the book don't get too much
into terraforming we are talking about
more of like the early stage you know
how do you start a society what's legal
when you get there what kind of health
problems would you have um but I uh I
don't know I mean it would be nice if
Mars were warmer but uh but I'm not sure
we're going to be able to do that and
and one one thing I would add to that is
like and this never comes up in
terraforming conversations but is like
whatever plan you want to use whether
you're like hurling comets and asteroids
at the Marchant poles or you're like
detonating 80 trillion Fusion bombs what
geopolitical legal framework countenance
is this like who's doing it right like
suppose tomorrow Vladimir Putin says I
want to throw I mean he can't but let's
say he's surprised us all and this whole
time they've been building Fusion
powered space vehicles and he's like
we're about to hurl the Comets don't
worry they won't hit Earth they're going
to lots of clearance and they'll hit
Mars on Target and terraform it and
we're going to do that cuz it's great uh
like we don't even know how to think
about that that's obviously
extraordinarily dangerous uh and
and in terms of like international law
it's very ambiguous whether that's
allowed it I would say it seems to me
like it probably is but there are
environmental concerns um so you have to
contact another country with I'm
concerned about your environmental
impact right yeah so it is in some sense
it would be legal but like I I think
obviously terrifying and I don't know
like that that seems to me like not a
like quibble
and it would totally tank the uh space
settlements no one in the next you know
20 30 Generations would be able to do it
especially if you hit it with nuclear
weapons yeah and that that's the other
thing by the way so I would say like if
we're talking about terraforming then
you're talking now on the like the
Millennium scale not on uh okay yeah and
also we're not even that great at
fine-tuning the temperature of the
atmosphere here on Earth
amen so you but you did mention comets
so let me very briefly get that
on the table so there's an idea that we
can use comets as raw materials right
like comets have water and ice and
volatiles and maybe mining them or
bringing them to our space settlements
might be a very long-term future goal
sure uh yeah the the only thing I would
say about that is you have to be really
care we we didn't put this in the book
but we started calling it something like
the elemental perspective which is is a
very sort of engineer physicist way to
look at how to survive which is like
well do you have enough carbon and
hydrogen therefore you can make life you
have to be really careful what else do
you need yeah well you need some sulfur
and
phosphorus but but yeah so you know a
really good example of this and this is
a g but we're allowed to go in depth on
the show okay yeah so um you will hear
over and over Harrison Schmidt the only
Senator geologist astronaut pushes this
the idea that we'll go to the moon and
get helium 3 a rare isotope of helium
that is indeed quite valuable uh and the
idea usually is that we will use it in a
fusion drive and it's this especially
cool Fusion Drive I believe the usual
reaction is with um duum and it's it's a
neutronic so you won't even have to like
fix the walls they didn't get radiated
in your tokom MAAC or whatever so yay um
the problem with this idea is that one
obviously we don't have the fusion
device and it actually uses like an
exotic reaction when we can't even do
the easier one yet which seem seems to
matter two two I think the a neutronic
business is overstated I kind of feel
like if you've got Fusion working with
good old dyum tridium like the job is
done go home uh but but I think more
importantly there's not that much it's
at higher concentration than you find on
Earth but in order to get a reasonable
quantity you're like strip mining a huge
amount of the surface of the Moon which
like separate from whe how we feel about
that like try to imagine building
equipment to work in this no air low
gravity two weeks night two weeks day
Etc environment like the idea that
you're going to make money doing this is
crazy Michelle Van Pelt who's a
scientist at ISA and this this is five
years ago so maybe the equation has
slightly changed but he said this almost
verbatim I think if there were bars of
gold sitting on the moon it would not be
worth it to go get them now if you if
you change the economics if you say well
it's so valuable to have water on on
Mars than the economics change but like
I think that tells you something about
life on Mars right which is it's not
pleasant um so I'm you know I I think
like the the comments for water thing is
a cool sci-fi thing I'm I'm quite
skeptical that that'd be a good way to I
mean the one thing I would add with all
these conversations is Space Geeks you
get into arguments with them and they're
like well I'm talking about the next
10,000 years you're like okay I I think
the prediction Horizon right now is like
50 years so if you want to talk about
10,000 years that's fine but but can't
argue right yeah right so so if I
understand then the attraction to Mars
versus the moon uh it has more water it
has more carbon dioxide Etc uh but it's
not that we're literally going to be
farming on the surface of Mars it's just
that we have have the raw materials out
there to mine or collect and bring to
our underground or enclosed settlements
yeah and it's still going to be awful
like know that that soil that you might
want to plant your plants in it's about
1% per chlorates which is a chemical
that binds to the hormones hormones made
by your thyroid and those hormones
regulate things like you know blood
pressure heart rate stuff like that so
you're going to like want to remove that
because Studies have shown that it does
get up by plants when you grow plants in
them and so first you're going to have
to like pull the per perchlorates out of
the soil before you can even start your
farm and there's there's all kinds of
the dust storms those are going to be
miserable and they're going to make uh
solar panels difficult like you yes it
has more of what we need but it's still
gonna suck right that's fine okay good
good but at least now I know the
motivation such as it is for continuing
on beyond the Moon to Mars but you
mentioned you know if the goal is
sustainability that does include human
beings reproducing so someone's going to
have to sex on in space at some point I
don't know when but then they're going
to give birth yeah they're gonna they
will talk about it uh there might be
videos I don't know but uh they then
they will give birth and that's a whole
another can of worms as it were what do
we know about both giving birth or for
that matter being pregnant but also
being a baby on the moon or on Mars we
we know can I do this yeah please we
know almost nothing so uh we very rarely
send up rodents with the goal of
understanding sex or reproduction or
development and when we do they're sent
up for a small window of the gestational
period so they're like shot up at you
know incredible G's they're pushed back
against their cages they're up in space
for like a week floating around and then
they fall back down to Earth At
incredible G's and then they look to see
what happens and maybe not surprising ly
uh a lot of stuff seems to go wrong
right that's probably very stressful uh
We've recently started making these like
Wheels uh that spin and create
artificial gravity that are on the
International Space Station little tiny
ones little tiny ones for rodents uh and
we've started to train astronauts to
euthanize the rats and process them in
space so you don't get that final trip
back down that's very stressful but
that's pretty much where we are we
haven't we don't even have rodents that
have like had sex had B those babies
survived and they went on to have babies
none of that has happened in space so
far so we really don't understand uh one
how gravity impacts reproduction so as
we mentioned the International Space
Station has effectively no gravity
whereas these other places have some
gravity and maybe that's going to be
enough but maybe not we don't really
know uh and then also the International
Space Station is protected by Earth's
magnetosphere so those rodents are not
exposed to space radi that you'll get on
the moon or on Mars and maybe you can
shield with like a thick layer of
regolith and protect everyone from that
radiation but we really don't understand
the impacts of that stuff yet and how
well that's all going to work out so I
would we would say that there's huge
question marks about whether or not this
is going to go well uh and to us that
seems unethical and usually this is
something that the space Community seems
to just sort of not deal with directly
but when they do deal with it directly
it's horrifying like we quotes of people
saying like look life is going to be
really hard on Mars initially and
everybody's going to need to be pulling
their weight and so we might have to
like encourage people to get abortions
if it looks like their kids are not
going to be able to contribute and but
what does that mean for like things
disabilities that come on at three year
three years of age or something are we
going to be pushing toddlers out of
airlocks and it just anyway this this
all gets very uncomfortable the more you
think about it so that's part of why we
want to see research stations on the
moon we'd like to at least least know
that it works okay at 16g and that we
can do this without too many calamities
when people can still get sent home in a
couple days as opposed to being stranded
on Mars and the space radiation Point
makes me uh I should have gone back to
our road map and pointed out I guess it
won't be like glass domes on the moon or
Mars It Will we will literally be either
building giant shelters with a lot of
shielding or just going underground yeah
I think that's right so
you know there there is some World maybe
in which you have plants in a martian
glass D although understand you have
almost no pressure outside and at least
some you know atmosphere inside so
already the problem is extraordinarily
difficult from a like materials
perspective um but but at least in
principle you could do that because you
know the plants might survive okay you
could let in carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere but yeah you you human
strolling around is going to be a
problem and it's it's a problem that
actually has weird consequences so I
don't remember if we get into this but
like as an example one question is what
happens to gametes in human bodies you
know those are those are precious gtes
if you want to have generations and
women start life with their full gamet
load whereas men uh produce their whole
lives and so like would you have
gender-based rules for who has to stay
underground that doesn't seem great um
but uh or age har environment yeah know
it's that's right yeah so but that's the
thing though so you can you can always
say like well it's just going to be
different because it's a settler
lifestyle but it's like do we really
want to create this horrible lifestyle
right and if you can anticipate ahead of
time that it's going to be horrible then
don't send people there well and also
unless you literally are worried about
the Earth coming to an end somehow right
what is the benefit of building an
underground city on the moon or Mars
rather than underground city on earth
which doesn't seem to be very popular as
a prospect absolutely yeah yeah so one
example we'd like to go to is you know
it would be far easier to build a city
on the bottom of the sea right and so if
you have a selfs standing bottom of the
ocean City it's really hard to imagine
what could happen to Earth that would
eliminate that city um you you know like
like we actually as an intellectual
exercise you know ask yourself what you
could do to Earth to make it as bad as
Mars right to just you know like like
the only thing I could come up with was
you'd have to slam it with a lot of very
large asteroids you'd basically have to
like superheat the surface to get
anything like Mars um Earth is good but
but I'll say like Earth is really good
but like I do I do still feel like it's
a beautiful idea to have humans on Mars
like I I like the idea of it happening
at some point even if we're living
underground like ants it's still feels
like a awesome it still seems awesome to
me but I just think we should do it in a
way that has you know fewer ethical uht
ethical issues well and also let's admit
to the force of the argument for backing
up the biosphere right you know maybe
there would be a terrible thing that
happens on Earth and it is the only
place we are now I absolutely see the
impact of an argument that says if
literally the existence of life is in
danger we should go to Great Lengths to
prevent that disaster from happening
yeah yeah I would say that and we
basically agree with that over the long
term the the the two points of push back
on that are one that like you have to
say like because that's essentially an
argument to spend a bunch of money
whether or not there's an Roi on it
right it's like it's an ought argument
we ought to do this uh outside of
Economics so the problem is one almost
certainly a dollar is better spent on
something else reducing catastrophic
risk at least in The Next Century yeah
so one like if you if you sort of list
uh um as Toby or does uh like the the
set of calamities a bunch are going to
be higher than uh annihilation of the
species on earth that could be salvaged
by a Mars base the other push back which
is longer term is the big question if
you're just talking about existential
risk I do think it's a kind of open
question whether settling Mars increases
or decreases over the long-term
existential risk because you you know we
we only talk about this briefly it's
about as speculative as we want to get
but interplanetary Warfare has like
nightmare potential because like you
know one of the reasons I mean this this
is a whole debate like why don't we use
gas weapons typically on each other and
they're they're like psychological
reasons of course but one reason is that
gas doesn't know which way to go um and
and same with biowarfare there's some
things you don't do because it might
come back at you well if you throw these
things down a a gravity well the the
risk is lower um or at least it would be
very hard to get the the disease back to
you you know there's six months between
places um so so you know it's just
speculative but like you know is worth
in in your equation adding that there is
at least some risk of the existential
risk increasing as a result of going
multiplanetary in the same solar system
well I I think the existential risk
increases in the near- term as well so
you know for example if we're starting
on the moon which we probably will uh
there's very very small surface area
that's like the best spots on the moon
and those are the spots where you've got
water and where you've got the the rims
and you can get more uh your solar
panels can get light for more of the
time so it's very clear where we're
going to be scrambling for when we start
going to the moon and we have this
international law regime that's sort of
unclear about what you're able to do
when you get there and right now we've
got this new emerging space race between
China and the US for these great spots
on the moon and whereas the space race
with the Soviet Union was more who can
just touch down first and that's it now
with China and the us we're talking
about places you're going to set up for
forever and people started lunar
economies and it sounds more like a
Scramble for land and you know between
nuclear wielding superpowers who are
getting along less and less well as time
goes on so that's
concerning I liked the TV show space
force I know a lot of people didn't but
I thought it was hilarious with Steve
Carol sorry that that one got uh
canceled but it was about exactly those
issues so we should take them seriously
I think um but okay so basically you're
saying that in our the irony would be
that in trying to eliminate some
existential risks we've created a giant
new existential risk and that is
something we should worry about and if
you're interested in more on that you
should read Daniel dy's dark skies
because that whole book is about how
going to space is you know could be
really bad for Earth he's an
international relations guy so he's very
explicitly concerned with that aspect of
the
question okay well moving on to slightly
happier topics uh I'm a little bit
surprised that of the many science
experiments that have been done on the
space station we haven't done
multi-generational animal reproduction I
mean if we are serious like you say
about living in space we we got to do
that is are there plans to do that there
hopes so I I would say that there's a
couple problems so one Nas NASA is very
squeamish about sex uh they don't want
rat sex even even rat sex no it's like
it's hard to get access to the NASA
researchers who study sex because what
they say to journalists is very tightly
controlled uh and so Nas NASA doesn't
want to get in trouble with the
taxpayers they don't want to talk about
alcohol in space they don't want to talk
about sex in space and also you know I
would argue that the International Space
Station as far as I know the stated goal
of the space station wasn't as a
stepping stone to settlements right and
so if that's not one of the explicit
goals then you know there's plenty of
short-term things you want to understand
like you know the astronauts who are up
there for two years how is that
impacting their body and and can we keep
doing this or is it not safe for them
and so
go ahead yeah the the to to add to that
like so one way to think about NASA is
as this agency that started with the
Apollo program and it's all Apollo it's
all beating the Soviets it's a political
act and then that's done and then the
question is what now there's a historian
called named John lodon he's one of the
preeminent historians he referred to as
what happened afterward as a 40-year
identity crisis I think he might say 50
years now and so you you know if NASA
was set up as the settle the moon agency
then you would expect that on these
space stations we would have a
systematic series of experiments but we
don't it's one of the frustrating things
when you're trying to answer a question
about something like space psychology is
what you just have is 40 Years of grab
bag you have lots of experiments done by
lots of people in different settings
without a kind of unified we need to
know this for sure aspect and so you
know we talk about this at the very end
of the book if you were making the like
Zack and Kelly are in charge of the NASA
settles space agency or whatever one of
the priority things would be you would
want to orient around Orient around a
system systemic systematic program to
just answer questions um frustratingly
with a lot of space stuff that doesn't
have an objective measure you know like
loss of bone density or something uh
it's really hard to get answers in in
part because of that lack of
systematicity and so when you look at we
we tried to find every single experiment
we could relating to like gametes or
reproduction or reproductive health or
hormones and it's it's just there's just
a lot of experiments and you are there
to make sense of them there's not a kind
of like textbook approach uh so so that
is why we don't have that kind of thing
NASA is not dedicated to settlement or
anything like that as you you you do
make a pretty good case in the book that
when it comes to psychology uh you've
given the actual human subjects a huge
incentive to not tell the truth about
their psychology so basically nothing is
reliable no I know we read Stacks and
stacks and stacks of astronaut and
Cosmonaut biographies you know
translating them with Google translate
and they almost all lie about their
mental and physical health and and it's
the incentives you know if they say oh
you know what I'm actually I'm depressed
I'm having a bit of a panic attack you
don't get to go up for another flight
and so we found and and same thing like
you can't say oh you know what I'm
having some chest pain maybe it's a
heart attack you're not gonna go up to
space and so there were stories about
lot you know one guy thought he was
having a heart attack didn't say
anything another guy thought he had bone
cancer or was that the same guy the same
guy it was W cutting him yeah might be
bit of a
hypochondriac I guess so yeah uh Mike
main removed papers from his medical
records because somebody was stupid
enough to let him travel with them so he
just ripped him out but he said that he
would have lied about a glass eye uh if
he thought he could get away with it oh
the guy who cheated on a vision test oh
yeah he memorized those card tests where
there's a number hidden in the in the
dots so he memorized those there's
another story I think it was maybe
Basset who is an astronaut candid who
unfortunately died in an accident but I
believe he was the one who stayed up all
night jumping up and down to get his
down because there was a hey
limit and then I think you another one
or maybe it was the same one learned to
slouch just a little to get under the
the the limit But but so I think only
once has this actually been a problem
there was one Cosmonaut who went up who
had a health problem that had started
beforehand if he had admitted it they
probably wouldn't have let him go and he
had to come back and it was interesting
because one of the women cosmonauts
instead of being like oh poor guy she
was mad at him not because she was mad
at him because he didn't continue the
LIE she's like look we all lie the
problem isn't that he lied but if you
lie you have to suck it up and you
finish your mission and he messed stuff
up so she didn't get to go and so she
was Furious not that he lied but that he
didn't go all the way through with it
because that's what you're supposed to
do yes so there's some open questions
about the psychology I I do want to
maybe we can at least speculate about
the
physiology in particular of a newborn
baby like I'm going to guess a baby that
is Born and Raised on the moon will have
a tough time coming back to Earth at
least that's what my science fiction
readings would lead me to
believe yes no I agree with what I think
that was in the expanse uh also like I I
agree a baby that is developing under
you know one sixth or 40% gravity they
might not have bones that are strong
enough to survive entry through Earth's
atmosphere and then landing on Earth and
walking around and to be quite honest we
don't even know if you know human hips
can handle childbirth and after a
lifetime at you know some percent of
Earth's gravity yeah I was just GNA say
you should give the number on that so
like in microgravity what was it one
yeah you you lose 1.5% of aerial bone
mineral density density which I think is
a measure of osteoporosis so 1.5% of
that in your hips is lost per month per
month per month mon um but again that's
in complete freef fall you don't know
how much better that guess when you're
at 40% maybe that gets rid of the loss
entirely but maybe not and and one thing
I would add to that there's a great
quote I found an interview with April
Ronka who's like the person at Nasa
who's maybe the top babies in space
that's that's not the that's not her
title but you know what I
mean but someone had asked her and I
can't remember what book this was
something like hey are we gonna have
like longer legs on Mars and she said
something like I I don't know I don't
like it's a very human thing to be like
there's less gravity so longer legs but
there's there's all sorts of mechanisms
in your body and we don't know how
they're going to respond so there's
stuff that might be unpredictable which
means it might be fine as well like like
one of the big surprises of the early
space program was that you could eat
fine that was an open question like it's
kind of weird frankly that you can eat
and it basically Works apparently
burping is dicey but generally speaking
uh you know in zero gravity but like
generally speaking it works which is
like I don't know for me it's kind of
surprising like you can eat stuff and it
goes to the right place and in this body
gravity yeah yeah and okay I mean this
does speak to the idea that the first
time we go to Mars we won't be coming
back right the is it is it I've often
guessed but maybe you're the experts
here that the first humans to visit Mars
will be on a on a one-way trip because
it's just so difficult to come back and
then maybe if you have Generations there
they have no choice but not to come back
I don't know if if it were up to me the
first people to go to Mars would be like
you know six crew on a NASA Mission and
they come back yeah uh I I think there's
a lot that we need to learn and it would
be nice to go there stay for a little
while and and come back I don't think
the first time we send them there we
should be leaving them there I I don't
know that I mean I could be wrong I
don't think there are any serious
proposals to to just leave them there I
think usually there's some orbital
mechanic stuff but like I think there
there's actually a trajectory where they
would stay on March for like just a
month and then come back it's not
usually popular because like what a
waste the usual trajectory is like six
months inbound and then I think
something like two years later it's six
months outbound um but I think even even
with someone like Robert Zubin is very
much a daredevil when it comes to other
people's safety on their Mars trip uh
still proposes that you like send a
robot system ahead to rack up methane as
propellent on the way out so no I I
don't I don't know I'm I would say this
there's there's good evidence that there
would be volunteers for a one-way Mars
trip but I think at least if you're
talking about sending a few people out
for the very first boot boots on the
ground I I don't know of any proposals
that would just leave someone there um
make a well it does bring us to the
question of uh government versus private
efforts in these directions it would be
cheaper to send people there one way and
if it's not the government doing it like
you said there will be
volunteers so I'm very open to the
possibility that that will be first okay
well sure however so you know if Elon
Musk for example wanted to send a bunch
of people to Mars and just leave them
there uh according to international law
the things that happen on Mars are the
responsibility of the United States and
I'm assuming that Elon Musk is launching
from the US and he's from the US so he's
the US's responsibility so the FAA
should be thinking about the ethical
implications of this before they allow
it to happen so there is some oversight
but I you know with all the geopolitical
power musk seems to have right now as
showing with starlink and this Ukraine
stuff um I don't know maybe he'd get
away with it but it it's not like
private companies can make these
decisions completely on their own yeah I
I would also add like
you know there's this argument we
encounter a lot from space peoplei who's
like well it does you know so we talk a
lot about international law and we think
it matters and there are a lot of
constraints you'll get a lot of space
people who'll be like Elon Musk and me
are going to the moon and it's none of
your business and you have no way to
stop us because we have the Rockets
which is basically just bogus and if you
want to convince yourself ask yourself
if Elon Musk has ever said anything bad
about the Communist Party of China right
Elon Musk has business interests on this
planet and so if he does something that
actively antagonizes every country on
Earth
uh there are going to be consequences
that will make him sad uh well also if
if he goes so you know they in the
starling's terms of service he
essentially said you know like when we
go to Mars we're not going to be bound
by Earth law um that straightforwardly
flies in the face of international law
including treaties that have been signed
by the United States and so you know and
China and Russia all the major space
Powers uh this is a highly ratified
document so if he goes to Mars and is
like ha you idiots let me come here and
now we've got our own nation and I'm not
listening to anybody then it would be
the faa's responsibility to say fine
none of your resupply ships can take off
so like even after they leave we still
have some control if the US government
decides to exercise it I guess you know
I'm trying to think of your exact
question I suppose I don't know what
would happen if like Elon Musk paid for
a venture to uh the North Pole and it
was badly planned and everyone died like
what would be the consequences and I
honestly don't know it seems like when
Elon Musk does something no matter how
badly it goes everyone thinks it's cool
so I don't know Twitter yeah yeah X
don't agree yeah all right all right all
right but but so in terms of like the
sort of specifics I don't know but in
terms of like setting up a settlement it
would be a really bad move to antagonize
Earth and I would add one thing we talk
about is is people tend to talk about
these things as abstractions like a
settlement is set up by a private
company but in reality the private
company is from somewhere and so suppose
you say the private company quote
unquote private is from China that feels
geopolitically very different uh than
than it being from the US right so you
know if Elon Musk surprises us tomorrow
with 10,000 people on Mars I don't know
maybe the US is like hoay uh I I I I you
know China probably is not um so so you
know it's not like you know in Star Trek
Earth is a unified front uh and not yet
here in the real world they're going to
be particulars yeah well you do get a
lot and in an admirable way into the
legal side of things in the book so
let's just you know get that clear um
how much of legality has been settled
for these things there is of course the
outer space treaty that was a long time
ago maybe we're still paying attention
to it or is this a set of rules that are
going to be swept away once we get real
well so we hope not so so we are
certainly still paying attention to that
treaty and a couple others that came in
like the next decade after that and
those treaties still do things like you
know govern how our satellites move
around and who's responsible and you
have to register the satellites when you
send them up and so those those
documents are like living and we're
using them every day so then the
question is do the parts that relate to
the Moon uh in or like appropriation of
land is that going to get ignored when
we get there and certainly there are
plenty of people who propose that if if
you know if Earth gets there first we
should just scrap the outer space treaty
and sure it was great it helped us in
some other areas us consider so yeah you
said Earth consider oh
thank you if the US gets there first
will get there first yeah yeah yeah we
can feel pretty pretty sure about that
um but you know so some people think you
should scrap it but the important parts
of the outer space treaty uh the most
important part is it says you're not
allowed to appropriate land so if you if
if Elon Musk gets to Mars and he says
this is mcow and our this is this is my
country or my you know my city or
whatever that's that is not allowed by
international law but it is unclear if
he's allowed to do any mining on the
moon and sell that for profit and so you
know does is that different than
appropriation the US has made it clear
that our interpretation is that yes
extracting and selling resources is not
the same thing as appropriating that
land that is okay you can do that but I
think there's some countries
particularly in the developing world who
would say no we don't we're not okay
with that the Earth is or sorry the Moon
is supposed to be and the moon and Mars
and all the celestial bodies that's
supposed to be a Global Commons and you
don't get to do whatever you want to it
um and so and it's not just that you
can't do whatever you want I would add
that like if you try to do something
like that you are antagonizing most of
Earth most of the governments of Earth
it's it's non-trivial um and P and power
might override it might you know it
might be that the US is powerful enough
that we're just going to do it and we're
going to take our chances we kind of
hope not but but but the other thing I
would add to and this is you know as far
as I know we're the only book that gets
deeply into the sort of broader context
of international law think could be very
easy to read the outer space treaties
some sort of Freo 1960s law where we
commonize space but there was like a
moment of weirdness but actually that's
exact not exactly but very similar to
how the Antarctic treaty system works
very similar to how the seabed works so
every time in the 20th century Humanity
was called upon to regulate a newly
accessible region of the universe we
picked a Commons and that has been
sustained and the really important thing
oh sorry I was banging the desk you're
not supposed to do that bad sound um uh
the other point I wanted to make so so
people generally will say to us when we
talk about this they'll say something
like well it doesn't matter because once
there's big money to be made in space
all bets are off we're going to go get
it and the thing is one we don't believe
there's big money to be made in space
but set that aside in Antarctica there
were there was a push uh to make
something called crra happen crra I will
never remember what the acronym was not
I think they are is resources but the
idea was make it so that the commons of
Antarctica could be accessed for
resources and my understanding and this
is iffy if reasons I'll get to there's
at least some evidence there might have
been profitable mineral resources in
Antarctica remember it's a whole
continent that's never been mined right
and in
1998 uh the Consortium of nations in
Antarctica decided to put a moratorium
not just on exploiting but on even
looking to see if there was stuff to
exploit that is in force till 2048 and
can only be removed by unanimous
agreement so like there was a very
plausible case for getting resources and
the planet Earth said no and the reasons
were that we didn't want to get in a big
giant fight over it and that there was
an environmental outcry uh so it's it's
not at all obvious to me that we're
going to suddenly go get it uh uh no
matter what no matter what the
consequences are if there's money to be
made if I take the words of the outer
space 3D literally does that mean that
if someone else goes to the moon and
builds a habitat and then I fly up there
I can just like walk in and open their
fridge and you know sleep in their
living room you are supposed to give
them prior notice and ask nicely but but
that you you are supposed to be able to
like visit other people's stuff in space
uh they can tell you you know for safety
reasons I can't let you in uh you know
but but yes you are supposed to but I
should say I mean I I didn't think you
were going to go there and I love the
example of you going to the fridge by
the way there's no fridge on the is no I
think they just sent up a fridge
Sid uh but but what's funny it is
actually illustrative because like the
original agreement really countenance as
Nations it's it's you know I mean there
was a big debate at the time but really
it's for a two superpower world so you
know I don't think they were thinking
about a fridge
raid wer think about Sean Carol but they
should have been yeah I think the rules
are more about like formal can we come
over to the Chinese module and inspect
to make sure you're not doing something
that scares us and and to be fair the
space lawyers that I talked to were I
was like oh there's it's so vague and it
was made back then and things have
changed and they're like no that is a
feature not a bug we didn't know what
was coming we were we were vague so that
this stuff could get worked out later
and we wouldn't be hamstringing
everything and it's and I guess the
problem is that back then countries were
way more likely to work together to
solve stuff and now you can't get
anything related to space through the
United Nations uh well you can't get any
big formal treaty you can get
resolutions and things tons of
resolutions yeah sorry big highly
ratified treaties uh we haven't had
anything related to space since what
1975 and that wasn't ratified by most of
the country that mattered as far as it
as far as going to space it's
interesting I mean let's not let that
pass by too quickly our increasing
inability to work together on these
things would you chalk that up more to
the fact that when it was less realistic
we were more idealistic or is it just
that the world in general is less good
at working together so I I think that
when we first made these treaties we did
think that this stuff was going to come
faster than it did so I I do think that
there was concern when we started going
to the Moon that that that you know us
would get there first and then maybe
they'd start claiming stuff and you know
the Soviet Union might have worried
about that and so they they wanted to
cut that sort of stuff off at the pass
um and so why are we less good I so so
yeah yeah to to add a little to that so
like we have a quote there's a guy named
OS Oscar Shaker shackner or Shaker okay
his his name is Oscar and we quote him
he was an important international
relations guy international relations
people know him he wrote in the 50s that
he was concerned about a future where
people would plant the flag and make
claims like back in the bad 19th century
right yeah and so um there that concern
was already percolating and there's a
scholar named James Clay moltz and we
cite him and he argues I think pretty
convincingly that part of what happened
is that in the early 60s I think in 62
and 63 there were high atmospheric and
inorbit tests of nuclear weapons which
so thoroughly terrified everyone that
people were willing to come to the table
so in other words you know we actually
we talk about this as maybe relevant to
the current AI discourses it's like you
know we got space law not because well
not necessarily because everybody was so
good at working together back in the 60s
but in part because we had scared
ourselves um and there were enough
rational people to say that's that's
scary and then the one other thing I
would add is there is a kind of
pragmatic thing here which is there are
a lot more countries now um so so a lot
of you know the high era of
decolonization is 1945 to 1975 there was
still a lot to be done when the first
you know the treaty is signed 1967 the
first big proposal that's basically the
treaty is 1963 so there are just a lot
more countries now um and there's not
this sort of bipolar two big powers that
kind of run spheres and people obey them
like countries can say no to all of us
you know and so like there is just
simply a pragmatic aspect that that said
you know Unos the law of the sea uh with
a lot of negotiating over decades was
widely ratified except not by the
but okay um and that was 1994 so it's
not impossible um but but the law of the
sea there was some urgency you know
there was some urgency about figuring
out how territorial Waters and stuff
works where where space historically you
know post let's say like mid-70s has
felt non-urgent and that may be changing
with the the new advances in
technology so we're again if we're
obeying the outer space treaty we're
imagining that we have settlements uh on
the moon or on Mars but they're not they
don't belong to specific nation states
or for that matter to specific private
entities I guess same thing would
go just slight Nuance that the station
itself would probably belong to the the
the the nation and the company but the
land under it would not claim the
territory right so you get zany you you
could if you had a base the size of the
Moon in principle that base is yours uh
but the land under it is not okay and I
mean at some point again if I get any
lessons WR all my science fiction
reading uh a couple hundred years the
moon will revolt and shake off the
shackles of Earth and become their own
nation state that does seem like a
potential problem to me you know
especially as a US citizen we really
like having our own property we like
property rights it's possible that uh
the society that develops on the moon
will be less concerned about property
rights and stuff but you you can
definitely imagine them getting really
angry uh and revolting and and maybe one
day they get to start their own state
but uh yeah so so one of the chapters
we're really proud of like I I don't
know if it's anybody else's favorite but
it was like our favorite is one on state
creation which is you're like so you
there's deep Norm in international law
you you hear the words um uh not
self-determination territorial Integrity
like you've since the Ukraine Invasion
like every other word at the UN is
territorial integrity and this is a deep
Norm that Nations cannot be dismembered
and yet countries come into existence
from time to time um and it just turns
out there's a process and drastically
over over simplifying there's a lot more
detail in the book generally speaking it
is recognized that a group of people are
deeply put upon deeply oppressed they
may have some right to take part of a
country for themselves now the standard
is very high uh there's a big case in
1998 concerning Quebec which basically
said no although with a lot of nuance
they can't do it essentially because kqu
people however they feel about
oppression they can they can vote they
can hold office etc etc you know you
know like as opposed to say Jews in
1930s Germany or like Native Americans
for you know much of the last several
centuries a long time yeah very long
time yeah exactly so so the modern law
which obviously was not enforced the
19th century but the modern view is
there you know and the classic case for
this is Bangladesh if a people are under
deep oppression by some government they
may have a right to what's called
remedial secession um so there and
meaning so you can do this quote unquote
illegal thing of dismembering a Nation
if there's an extreme circumstance that
pertains to national identity and but
here for the first time you'd be taking
out part of the Global Commons and
making it the property of a group of
people which would be a sort of new
totally totally new thing but but you
can imagine it working out at some point
if they end up feeling super oppressed
if they're if they've been supered and
so the issue just to be clear like it's
not like you magically get to be a state
because you're oppressed it's just that
being oppressed makes you more likely to
be recognized by the global Community as
having a right to a particular territory
so there's some World in which you can
imagine for some reason a moon
settlement vaults and most of the
countries from Earth say immediately yes
that's legitimate even though they're
taking out of the commons but that's
very unexplored
territory okay I mean it does also it
gives me an opportunity to go back a
little bit because I think we maybe went
a little bit too quickly for my taste
over the self- sustainability question
like if the moon did want to secced they
would probably first want to not be
dependent on shipments from Earth so
precisely how realistic is that uh I
mean let's just say let's say it this
way is it within present technology if
we throw enough money at the problem or
do we need new scientific breakthroughs
to have a truly self-sustaining
settlement on the moon well so so first
I'd say that I think you can get a state
made even if they're not completely
self-sufficient because no state on
Earth is completely self-sufficient
either and so I I think the moon could
still come up with trade agreements with
different countries but create their own
state but in terms of what it would take
to be able to go uh to survive on your
own I think for us the clearest example
is uh the need for computer chips to run
your like your habitat is going to very
much depend on technology you're going
to need these computer chips at the
moment like what all the stations or all
the places that make it are in Taiwan
though we're trying to get one in the US
I'm not completely up to date on all of
this Zach probably is but like these are
things that require a lot of water it's
a very complicated Factory to make and
there's so lightweight that you know
they'd be real you could ship tons and
tons of them you know on a rocket you
could get a bunch of them to Mars for
example so it's gonna be a long time
before Mars is like all right we're
gonna make our own chip factory and also
when you think about like you know you
live in a big major country and you've
got Specialists for all these different
kinds of medical problems that you could
have like you know there's something you
know there's thousands of Medical
Specialties and so the number of people
that you would need to have like the
medical specialists that you need the
like Prof that you need the tech or the
engineers that you need we're probably
talking about like a million or more
people uh and what looks say something
yeah I was just I'm glad we'll have the
professors that's well know we're
important people we can we can do
without them okay but so so like Cuba
and North Korea are not even
self-sustaining and they have the
benefit of being able to breathe the air
when they walk outside and they still
need support and so you're going to need
huge populations to make this happen
it's going to be a while so we we did
try to find like is there a good
estimate for how many people you would
need on Mars to create autarchy and and
basically the answer is we don't know
there's not a good answer so I'm sorry
autarchy economic self-sufficiency yeah
so like you know historically some
communist countries have been interested
in this probably the closest country is
the dprk you know North Korea but they
still have plenty of interaction with
outside world and also it's awful there
uh and um so we did try to find numbers
there are some very handwavy numbers by
a couple people the lowest estimate we
found by a guy who was very Pro
settlement was 100,000 people and that
assumed extraordinary advances in Ai and
Robotics so it's a huge huge number of
people you're not talking it's not going
to be like it's not gonna be like a hind
line novel where there's like a hundred
tough guys and and they work it out you
know it's it's not gonna be anything
like that that's interesting is that
demanding a kind of modern first world
standard of living uh or is it really
just surviving from day to day well it's
I would say say it's a kind of
combination right so it's you're right
it's just surviving but like okay so if
you went to like if you found a deserted
island with like coconuts and pigs you
know you don't need a lot of Technology
right so you could live a happy non-ir
world existence on Mars you have to have
a first world existence in that you will
die without like a nuclear reactor and
computer chips and all sorts of stuff so
yeah so that that's the thing is it's
it's not like it's not like any
situation on earth right you you you
just can't exist without the technology
so you know you might not need I don't
know like someone running a SAA or like
like luxuries or whatever you might like
them but maybe you don't need them but
you certainly need like advanced
technology and that kind of thing yeah
maybe you have fewer Medical Specialists
and and fewer
professors but go ahead but yeah but but
yeah like Zach said you need the techn
yeah I can't remember we mentioned this
in the book but one thing that was
really eye openening for me in just
thinking about this question I I was
talking to an aerospace friend of ours
named Manfred Aeros we we're saying his
name wrong I'm sure is from Germany but
but anyway you know we were talking
about this question of like could you
even model how much like energy you
would need to run a million people on
Mars and you know we we decided that it
would take 30 grad students in 10 years
and it would be wrong by the time you
got an answer but like he pointed out I
thought this was a really good
observation he said you know on Earth
the cheapest most efficient way to shift
stuff from here to there is on a boat
right so somehow if you're calculating
your energy needs you have to factor in
that you no longer have free highways
between most of the cities on Earth and
so that and that's just one little thing
I mean so it's like you try to imagine
the energy needs you're going to need
with all the things we take for granted
go away it's going to be
extraordinary um so it seems like there
would be probably one big Metropolis on
the moon not uh that those million
people are not going to be in a 100
10,000 person settlements well it might
depend on the distribution of resources
on the moon so like you know you'll Pro
you might get them at both poles so that
there's enough water uh so I guess it
might depend on what it is that they're
mining um why are they there yeah yeah
it's also like so Kelly mentioned
earlier we have this thing with call
Premium real estate which is like
there's actually like the moon I think
has an area about the size of the
continental US so it's quite big the
actual desirable parts of the Moon are
teeny weeny um uh so I can imagine a
world in which so the one thing we
didn't talk about is lava tubes and like
by by the way we're being like
pessimistic lava tubes are like the
coolest thing in the whole solar system
and they're very close to us there these
Cas so Earth has Lava Tubes maybe some
of your listeners have been to the ones
in Hawaii imagine them blown up by like
100x that might be what they're like on
the moon they're models that at least
suggest that so like these absolutely
extraordinary Caverns which would be a
great place to set up a base because
instead of like bringing a habitat or or
building it on site you just seal off
the walls not that it's easy just seal
off the walls in lunar caves but like
you know once you do that you have your
bubble and then you can start doing the
other stuff and that protects you from
radiation and from temperature swings
and the reguli so so so the pop when you
say Metropolis like part of the
Metropolis is constrained by how big the
good spots are right so it might be more
like you know if if there are only half
a dozen really good lava tubes and we
know there's only a small number of
these places where you can get water in
Perpetual near Perpetual sunlight I I
would actually guess you'd have a small
uh set of distributed places also I
presumbly that would provide some level
of resiliency um if something went wrong
but but you know hard to speculate did
we learn anything from Biosphere
2 difficult it is to have a truly closed
ecosystem we learned how difficult it is
for sure so by 2 was 3.14 Acres
substantially larger and more
complicated than anything that we you
know could hope to make on Mars in the
next decade or two and in that system
one they had to pipe in oxygen because
the cement was messing with their
atmosphere and they all were getting
like headaches and stumbling around and
so they had to get more oxygen uh there
were stowaways there were these bark
scorpions which uh fun fact are the only
lethal scorpions in the US and they had
managed to get in there uh I think
cockroaches also were a problem they uh
there were there were problems that were
getting so the original plan was to run
this simulation many many times for
two-year periods and learn as you go and
there was stuff that they were learning
like the chickens that they picked
weren't laying enough eggs and the pigs
were trying to eat the chickens and the
mangoes hadn't start or was it bananas
or one of their fruit trees hadn't start
started to produce yet and so it I think
it just proves that one of the things
that it taught us is that it takes a
long time to figure this out and and to
be honest I think it also taught us that
you don't want to start with one giant
system you want lots of little ones
where you Tinker with a couple variables
and figure out how those work and then
you work on scaling up it also taught us
that human psychology is uh difficult so
it was what six groups eight eight who
split into two hateful factions where
they were literally sitting on each
other when they were angry um and they
needed to call out to therapists for
emotional report which is going to be
hard on Mars with a 22-minute
conversation delay you can't have live
chats with your psychiatrist uh if
you're on Mars and so I think yeah
there's a lot you don't want a
megalomaniac running the no yeah I mean
yeah yeah yeah the only thing I would
add is is you know eight people in these
three acres they were starving by the
end they were you know they lost between
10 to 18% of their body mass and and
that is with them working all day on
this system to try just to survive
they're not trying to do cool space
people stuff right they're just tring
did not die and all the power is
supplied from the grid right unless you
count incident light on the plants right
um but can I just say you know we all
make fun of Biosphere 2 and I'm there's
so many funny things about it and stupid
things they did but it's worth noting it
did basically kind of work um I I I'm a
believer that if you know I there was no
reason to do this but if the billionaire
they convinced to throw whatever it was
$200 million at this project uh if they
had continued it for the ensuing 30
years I do think we would have learned a
whole lot um because you know like the
last textbook written on closed loop
ecology is from like 2003 you know this
is a whole it's a cool thing like there
are a lot of interesting questions you
could what I can't buy that the last
textbook on
close3 okay we'll ask chat GPT at the
end um but but but but yeah so like you
know the big questions are things like
what is the optimal setup to like
generate consumables and almost
certainly their system which was you
know the guy in charge was this kind of
crazy dude named John Allen who was like
three quarters artist one quarter
engineer and so they did a lot of crazy
stuff like they they were like we went a
ghost desert uh which is not a thing
with ghost it's like an actual ecosystem
but like so we went at Coral Reef it was
like very 90s Captain planety you know
and and so presumably if they were a
little more careful they probably should
have just made the whole thing
agriculture uh and and some other stuff
but like who knows maybe those biomes
were really useful yeah um so we could
have found out a lot but I still feel
like that money would have been spent
better on lots of
so for example China has lunar Palace uh
and they had a situation where they had
three crew members in their like closed
loop system and their the breathing
gases where it was like too much carbon
dioxide was building up so they switched
out two big guys for two smaller women
and then it worked and that that's where
we are right now like where you got to
stop around mass to to make it work and
so like we don't have the science
figured out yet with like all the
calculations you'd want before you send
someone to Mars so there's still a lot
to learn I'm guessing it will would make
sense even if maybe it's not absolutely
necessary for the first Martian colonist
to be all
vegans
yes I would the only thing I would say
about that I'm a vegetarian and you're
you're almost certainly right in terms
of like converting energy to calories
but you know psychology is a thing you
know like you can you can be you know if
you look at the very early NASA food
it's literally like food cubes and
gelatin stuff and everyone hated it so I
I do think you want to be open to
tolerate some level of inefficiency for
like sanity when a lot of the proposals
we saw for early settlements they were
proposing um meal worms and crickets as
like a protein Source because those are
easy to grow and you can grow them on
the like scraps from the vegetable
garden yeah uh and then there is a lot
of proposals for uh cellular meat so if
you can grow like right beef in a vat uh
and that technology seems to be making
pretty good gains uh but the closely
Loop ecosystem people that I talk to
we're pushing for like fungus and you
know you can make fungus taste like Lan
vegetar yeah vegetarianism maybe not
veganism yeah um right here on the cover
of your book there's a little
perspective drawing of a settlement and
one of the very few buildings that is
labeled is called Cricket
Ranch so so so yeah very very briefly I
guess the evidence is that the bigger
the animal the less efficient you're
going to get at converting energy to
calories right so so you're not eating
beef uh you're not eating chicken just
keep going down you'll arrive at
something like crickets and uh and that
is the set I mean again I mean there are
I should say we're we're we're Americans
there are places where they eat crickets
and it's not a big deal and it's not
weird it's a normal dietary item so like
maybe just don't send westerners send
those people they're they're obviously
better adapted to to this environment
send the Buddhists they'll just be
exactly and I mean speaking of
potentially unanticipated resource needs
we're reading a lot of Articles these
days about giant Computing facilities
that are either doing crypto mining or
AI calculations and they need both a
tremendous amount of energy but also a
tremendous amount of cooling right a
huge amount of water is being used up by
these are is that something we're just
not going to be able to have on the moon
or is there some more clever way to
answer these problems yeah that's a
really interesting question uh you know
fun fact Biosphere 2 actually had a
Computing Center in its basement uh this
was 1993 or something was called the
technosphere because that's how they did
things um and then they actually needed
it though to monitor all the ecological
stuff so I I doubt it's going to be on
the scale of like some crazy crypto rig
or like whatever they're doing for these
um llms but like you you are going to
need something right because remember
again you're you're you're surviving on
technology so if something goes wrong
with like the CO2 scrubbing or some
weird gas has entered the environment or
whatever you do need a system monitoring
everything um in terms of cooling that I
I actually have no idea I mean assume
what you do if you didn't have water I
guess you could dig down like because
these are not seismic well they're
lightly seismically active so maybe it
would be like very cool underground or
something but honestly I don't that's
that's not something we thought deeply
about I think there's enough water on
Mars that you could do it without too
much trouble I mean it would be a pain
to get it initially you'd want to um
pretty far along I would think but yeah
when they're they're working on uh
nuclear reactors for Mars to help
provide more power because you know on
Mars you get these dust storms that can
last for weeks and they sort of are hard
to predict and so you're not going to
want to rely on your solar panels uh so
you know you could use some nuclear
power too yeah but I would just just say
like questions like that are part of why
this is so difficult because you tend to
think in terms of like well we need a
box of oxygen and some food but actually
there's all this little stuff
survival all right we're we're reaching
the end but I have a couple of uh very
easy questions to wrap up with one is we
already touched on this a little bit but
war in space uh I think part of the
outer space treaty is you're not
supposed to send weapons up there but
it's a little bit vague on military
operations more generally I mean is this
as we might have imagined back in the
60s is this a whole new theater for good
old nationalistic countries to work out
their aggressions on on each other so
you're not allowed to spend send weapons
of mass destruction um so I think
technically you could like you know
strap a gun to your satellite uh and use
it to shoot another
satellite but that would be very much
frowned upon uh so at at the moment I
think it's mostly folks don't want to be
starting an arms race uh on the moon and
in the United Nations there's
resolutions all the time to you know how
are we going to deal with this potential
emerging arms r
in space uh we already from Land shoot
down satellites that are in space and
we've never shot down another country
satellite but we have shot down our own
country satellite just to make sure
everyone knows that we can do that um
Russia actually threat it well go ahead
yeah didn't China shoot down one of its
own satellites from space didn't get in
trouble for doing that I thought they
had shot it down shot a ground to space
missile but I think it was ground space
and they they got in trouble because it
was high enough up that the debris is
going to take a really long time to fall
and that was what got them in trouble to
compare India did an ASAT test I think
in 2019 and you know people frowned upon
it but it was in very low earth orbit so
it was like less of an environmental
issue yeah we didn't even mention Space
trash and space debris overall is that
overblown or is that going to be one of
the real
concerns uh we have less expertise on
that I mean Space is really big and it
hasn't been a problem yet I do think
there's a tendency to think crazy space
billionaires because they're crazy space
billionaires don't care about this stuff
but there are actually systems in place
for everyone to communicate with
everyone and to move stuff up and down
and I mean I wouldn't want to be living
in a rotating space station in low earth
orbit with all that debris but I
wouldn't worry about it if I was on the
moon or Mars or L5 or something like
that right yeah I mean you have to
remember it's like you know so if you go
to 300 miles that's one shell if you go
to 310 that's another shell 320 that's
another showell and these are all I mean
of course everything's going quite fast
uh but but you know I mean for example
there I forget the exact number it's say
like 37 nuclear reactors are in space
currently uh between I think like 700
and a th000 miles high and I don't think
you know it's obviously a weird thing to
say but I don't think people actually
worry too much about them nuclear
reactors in space yeah it's absolutely
true but we don't really worry about it
that much okay so then here's the last
question we we sort of squirted around
this one how much is this going to cost
like it seems like it'll be very
expensive to put a million people in a
city on the mo Moon and and maybe we can
fold into this if we if you done a very
very good job I think of of of Set uh
letting us know all of the worries and
maybe the extent to which people don't
take the worries seriously enough but if
we allow ourselves to be a little
optimistic when could this possibly
happen if everything broke right for us
uh so how much does it cost and when is
it going to happen sure uh so cost uh I
mean so let me just say a priori in both
these questions I'm going to have to be
fairly handwavy but so on the on the
question of cost it's tough and I'll
tell you why so if you look at the
International Space Station there
different estimates on what that has
cost so far but it's something like 150
to2 200 billion dollars extraordinarily
expensive that's for six a crew of six
in a room about the size of a nice
apartment uh so you know what what what
a person a space Advocate would say I
think correctly is that as costs fall
that'll get way cheaper um and uh but
but as you know I think Jonathan mcdal
pointed out to us the modules are a huge
part of that cost like it's not like
launches doing everything those modules
are very expensive but so the thought is
you get to a world where you're actually
mass-producing the modules like for
space hotels or whatever then maybe you
can really drop down the price I mean so
we talk about how depending on how you
count it you can get a little fuzzy with
the numbers but between 1957 say and
like 1970 the cost of going to space
putting stuff in orbit anyway dropped by
maybe as much as 99% it hasn't happened
since but since 2015 there are different
estimates but let's say it's dropped by
like three quarters that's a pretty fast
decline right so you know there so what
I'm saying is essentially there reasons
to believe it'll be zany expensive but
the scaling the rocket launch really
does matter um and in ways you might not
anticipate it's not just that it's
cheaper to get stuff to space it means
you can use more off-the-shelf parts
because you don't have to fit it exactly
in the fairing of the one vehicle you
have so there is a huge amount of room
for cost drops um which is part of why
we got interested in this topic in the
first place so I I I really wouldn't
want to give a number but I would say it
might be it's a huge number it might be
smaller than you think I think I mean I
think if like the US decided tomorrow we
have to have a moon a Mars base with
with a thousand people that you're
probably talking trillions like you're
talking about a zany amount of money but
in terms of like the space business
scaling over the next 50 years uh you
know uh there are possibilities it's
very path dependent you know like if if
like you know lock he Martin said they
were making a compact Fusion device I
don't believe them but suppose they were
they they did uh that would change the
equation a lot in terms of time
scales I think I think time scales it's
so hard to predict because it really
depends on what people decide as a
priority and so you know if the US
decided we are absolutely in a space
race with China the president and
everybody in the Senate agreed we threw
a ton of money at it we could maybe make
that happen
soonish but but I but I don't know but
but the whole a huge part of our book is
arguing that we shouldn't be doing it as
fast as we can we should be stopping and
first we should be doing more biology
experiments to get a handle on the risks
so that we can you know reduce the
ethical problems and if you've got more
time maybe you can work out a system
with the International Community for who
gets to extract what and how are those
profits shared and do you get to decide
that this land belongs to a certain
group of people so that they don't
Revolt in 200 years and can Sean car
Sean Carroll eat your ice if he shows up
on the moon like probably the most
important question and so very important
we would like to see this take
decades um but it could be rushed one
one last little thought on that which
which I've been thinking about recently
is you we said earlier the lowest bound
number we'd ever found on
self-sustaining settlements was 100,000
and it was based on an assumption about
huge developments in Ai and Robotics and
I kind of laughed about it two years ago
uh and that's changed and so it's funny
like there's still parts of those
proposals I'm skeptical but you know
like you wonder about if in 20 years
there's a world where we have like
Fusion figured out and you can just send
robots to set everything up in advance
that really does change the picture um
so that's why we're we're very
uncomfortable predicting because the the
the place from which the advance comes
may be surprising yeah well I did a few
months ago talked to Joseph silk who is
a very well-known cosmologist who just
came out with a book proposing
telescopes on the moon right astronomy
on the moon and there's very good
science case to be made for them and and
he mentioned his book just came out like
earlier this year he said when he was
writing the book uh he said you're going
to need human beings to maintain the
telescopes and by the time the book came
out he like well yeah maybe we could
have an AI you know in a robot
maintaining the telescope so a whole new
existential risk has opened up because
we're going to make a city of robots
artificially intell robots on the moon
and give them high technology what could
possibly go wrong yeah I think to button
that up like to me that speaks to the
nature of the problem which is like you
know there's like a hind line vision and
the Star Trek vision and hind line is a
Hard Scrabble we're going to do this as
people Star Trek is the world has worked
out so we're doing it for aesthetic
reasons I think that's much more
plausible all right I like that that's a
wonderful place to End Kelly and Zack
wieners Smith thanks so much for being
in the mindescape podcast thanks for
having us thank you
[Music]
w